wir reden über zensur bei youtube herz
denn bei der video plattform wird
offenbar gelöscht was nicht so ins
meinungsbild passt so zum beispiel
wurden jetzt einige videos der aktion
alles auf den tisch von youtube gelöscht
ein fall für die richter laut youtube
der verstoß gegen unsere richtlinien zu
medizinischen fehlinformationen also das
ist tatsächlich ein fall für die richter
das gucken wir uns noch mal ganz genau
an diesen fall und
das habe ich sehr schnell geahnt dass
wird die angst sein dass es wird ein
angst getriebenen gesellschaft sein wo
sehr viele menschen
unsicher sind nicht wissen was sie tun
sollen angst haben und dann nach einem
retter suchen wir haben diese immunität
gegenüber dem wildtyp haben wir in der
bevölkerung die normalerweise im empfang
unterwegs ist also nicht die ganz alten
möglicherweise aber in diese
bevölkerungskreise haben wir die längst
erreicht also sagen wir ich zurückkomme
allein haft aus dass grund virus
sie gehen davon aus dass sozusagen eine
immunität für das grund virus wir leben
nicht von den varianten zu dem zeitpunkt
schon gegeben war habe ich das richtig
zusammengefasst das haben sie ganz
perfekt zusammen gefasst
darüber müssen wir sprechen dann bei uns
ist jetzt bildpolitik chef jan schäfer
und wir wollen diskutieren wie
gefährlich ist es auch für die
demokratie wenn hier so eingegriffen
wird wenn sich dass sie eine aktion von
schauspielern von kreativen die sich mit
experten zusammengesetzt haben gespräche
geführt haben und diese dann auf youtube
hochgeladen haben kritische gespräche
zum thema corona wie gefährlich kann so
eine zensur dann werden wir sehen ja die
gefährlichkeit schon am urteil was es
jetzt gab des kölner landgerichts das
gestern ja gesagt hat das ist nicht
zulässig gewesen das entspricht also
nicht dem den regeln dem
demokratieverständnis und den vorgaben
den gesetzlichen vorgaben die es gibt
und da erkennen wir dass das was da
passiert es einfach nicht rechtmäßig war
und was nicht rechtmäßig ist ist am ende
in unterschiedlichen facetten immer
gefährlich für unser zusammenleben für
den staat an sich hilft das eigentlich
wenn deutsche gerichte das sagen also
wie wir alle wissen sitzt die firma
youtube nicht hier irgendwo in
eisenhüttenstadt oder paderborn ist es
ein bisschen schwierig da an die chefs
sozusagen ranzukommen also bringt das
überhaupt was wenn die deutschen
gerichte diese meinungsfreiheit schützen
wollen und youtube aber einfach fleißig
weiter luft wir haben es hier in
deutschland mit einem durchaus verengten
meinungs- korridor bei einigen themen zu
tun das haben wir festgestellt gerade in
der korona pandemie das meinungen die
möglicherweise nicht dem mainstream
angehörten also die nicht dass
wiedergaben was die regierung gerne
hören wollte dass die sehr schnell eine
ecke gerückt wurden die extrem war da
hieß es dann sofort ja das ist ja eine
querdenker oder das ist ja eine afd
meinung oder argumente die sozusagen aus
der extremen rechten ecke dann auch
kommen und das ist natürlich total
gefährlich dass man einen diskurs so
verengt dass man gar nicht mehr richtig
diskutieren kann sobald man nicht das
sagt was angela merkel beispielsweise
gerne möchte wie man denkt so und in
diesem korridor haben wir uns durchaus
bewegt über bild haben das nie mit
gemacht das muss man auch ganz deutlich
sagen sind dafür auch sehr hart
kritisiert worden aber wir sehen ja
jetzt auch mit dem löschen dass dieses
überhaupt möglich ist dass da selektiv
etwas raus gegriffen würde die
begründung war ja auch völlig abstrus
also es gab ja keine richtige begründung
sondern das war so im ungefähren also da
muss man sagen das ist gefährlicher
eingriffe die hier stattgefunden haben
zu recht hat das gericht anders
entschieden schauen wir uns einmal ein
paar ausschnitte an mit denen youtube
ein solches problem hatte dass es diese
ausschnitte eben vorübergehend hat
löschen lassen
ja unter anderem hier sehen wir noch mal
die begründung von youtube dazu aber wir
wollten eigentlich einmal ein paar
ausschnitte zeigen aus diesen videos die
youtube dann hat sperren lassen was sind
das für beispiele jan mit den youtube da
offenbar ein solches problem hat dass
sie gesagt haben kommt weg damit das
muss sofort raus aus dem netz wir haben
ja in der begründung ja auch gerade
schon gesehen um was es geht und da geht
es dann um diese frage ist das
eigentlich medizinisch richtig zu
bewerten ja was da gesagt wurde und die
große frage ist ja ja kann das den
youtube eigentlich
beurteilen also wer sitzt da und sagt
das ist jetzt medizinisch richtig oder
falsch ich erinnere einmal anders doch
robert koch-institut dieses mächtige
institut was gott gleich ja schon in
dieser pandemie eigentlich gewesen ist
und wir stellen fest dass robert koch
institut hat uns zahlen über monate
genannt bei der impfquote die offenbar
der realität gar nicht entsprochen haben
sondern möglicherweise mehrere
prozentpunkte sogar zu niedrig lang das
heißt wir haben auch corona politik
gemacht die auf falschen zahlen beruhte
und auch da muss man dann sagen ja wenn
es schon so weit ist dass das robert
koch institut mit falschen zahlen kommt
ja wer denn eigentlich dann beurteilung
gerade bei youtube ob das was da jetzt
in diesem trio oder in diesen in diesen
filmen auch gesagt wurde ob das richtig
oder falsch ist kann doch gar keiner vor
allem erwehren auch mal drei dinge
herausgesucht mit denen youtube sogar
kein problem beispielsweise hat
russlands präsident putin da zum
beispiel gegen navalny hetzen der hamas
chef gegen israel und chinas präsident
darf propaganda über corona verbreiten
also dass alles super youtube gelöscht
wurden von youtube arbeitet youtube muss
man also ganz klar fragen hiermit
doppelstandards ja stattdessen war
offenbar die aktion alles auf den tisch
so gefährlich teil dieser aktion war
auch der anwalt joachim steinhöfel und
der hat diesen fall dann eben auch vor
gericht getragen bis eben jetzt die
richter gesagt haben das gar nicht so
sein das darf nicht einfach gelöscht
werden von euch bei youtube wir sind
jetzt verbunden mit joachim steinhöfel
und wollen über genau diesen fall von
zensur sprechen schönen guten tag herr
steinhöfel und morgen schildern sie
einmal den moment als sie erfahren haben
dass von dieser aktion alles auf der
tisch einige videos gelöscht worden was
ist ihnen da durch den kopf gegangen ja
also ich bin ja schon recht hart
gesotten weil ich habe schon 2018 mit
unserem büro die gäste anfällige
verfügung erwirken facebook was an
lösungen angeht auf sozialen netzwerken
also ich bin ja derjenige der das
angeleiert hat sozusagen die eigene die
rechtliche möglichkeit überhaupt gegen
löschung und sperrung vorzugehen man hat
da wirklich schon sehr sehr viel erlebt
wenn man sieht was gelöscht wird dann
ist das so oft so sprachlos machen und
so absurd auch teilweise durch
sogenannte künstliche intelligenz dass
das mich jetzt auch nicht weiter
überrascht hat ich muss ihnen allerdings
sagen als ich dann an servern videos
ganz angeguckt habe das video ins events
und gesehen hat wie nett und vernünftig
dort der professor seine thesen
erläutert da hat es mich am ende
wirklich da hat ist ich war so
erschüttert dass mir fast die tränen
gekommen sie das mag jetzt lächerlich
klingen ich kriege solche lösung jeden
tag aber dieser nette mann dieser
hochqualifizierte wissenschaftler
erklärt etwas und er wird einfach
ausgelöscht und das hat mir wirklich das
hat mir wirklich die füße unter dem
körper gezogen
wenn gerade darüber diskutiert wie
gefährlich so was ist wie gefährlich das
auch in zeiten wie diesen ist woher
vielfältig und offen darüber diskutieren
müssen was corona mit unserer
gesellschaft macht die aktion ja auch
gestartet um weiter zu informieren um
fragen zu stellen so zumindest das
erklärte ziel was löst das in ihnen aus
und wie groß bewerten sie diese gefahr
für uns alle
die ifa siemens andererseits sind die
sozialen plattformen aber natürlich auch
eine unglaubliche option um sich
überhaupt zu äußern denn die ganzen
menschen die dort jetzt aktiv sind die
konten vor fünf sechs jahren geworden
hatten überhaupt kein gehör im politiker
kann immer zu ihnen laufen oder zu den
öffentlich rechtlichen medien und hat
die chance gehört zu finden der normale
durchschnittsbürger hat hier die chance
das auch zu tun und er gewinnt entweder
zuhörer aus zuschauer oder editiert
insofern ist das eine sehr sehr positive
situation ist das möglich ist wieder
aber gelöscht wird und wie dort
eingegriffen wird und dann auch mit so
schwammigen begriffen wie hass und hetze
statt strafbare enthalte das verschlägt
an die sprache und das wird auch bewusst
von der politik gesteuert denn die
politik hat nur schwer einfluss auf das
was die menschen was die bürger auf die
in den sozialen medien sagen wenn es
strafbar ist muss es natürlich gehandelt
werden aber wenn wir das die debatte
verlagern so bereiche wie hass und hetze
warum sagt man nicht verleumdung
beleidigung volksverhetzung
das sind straftatbestände das darf man
nicht aber mit hass und hetze wird das
alles nebulös und leute denken ja das
kann der hass und hetze seien ich halte
mal lieber den mund und das ist genau
das was man will diese verlängerung des
meinungsforschers und dann wird das
kommt hinzu dass gelöscht wird was das
zeug hält und dann denken die leute
natürlich auch bei 30 tagen sperre da
wird schon irgendwas zu recht erfolgt
seien in vielen fällen jedenfalls das
heißt die grenze ist ja eigentlich
längst ganz klar gezogen durch unser
grundgesetz wie kommt man aber jetzt
nachhaltig tatsächlich an youtube ran
also das urteil der richter jetzt ist ja
erstmal ganz gutes zeichen aber bringt
das nachhaltig überhaupt was bei dem
konzern der wie wir wissen eben seinen
sitz nicht in deutschland hat das ist
nicht so schlimm der sätze sind irland
aber was schlimm ist das obwohl ich das
im rechtsausschuss des bundestags
diverse male angesprochen habe die
politik immer noch nicht in der lage war
und das ist noch mal deutlicher auf hof
die ganzen großen netzwerke zu zwingen
ein zusteller bevollmächtigten in
deutschland zu benennen das heißt ich
habe diese einstweilige verfügung jetzt
das gericht in köln hat unglaublich
schnell reagiert und das war ist nicht
die norm in deutschland wo anders muss
man wesentlich länger warten jetzt muss
ich aber diese einstweilige verfügung zu
stellen in irland und das muss auf
diplomatischen wege geschehen und dauert
vier wochen das ist doch absurd warum
sagt stadtpolitik nicht ins gesetz große
plattform haben einzustellen
bevollmächtigten in deutschland zu
benennen für alle solche gerichtlichen
auseinandersetzung dann wäre die
einstweilige verfügung jetzt schon in
berlin bei den dortigen anwälten und die
videos müssten wieder online gestellt
werden google ist hier schräg gegenüber
google deutschland 30 meter dafür eine
demonstration statt los und die rettung
der welt geht ich hatte das flugplatz er
mitgenommen
da habe ich das gestern schon abgegeben
die wissen also seit gestern 17 uhr
bescheid dass sie die videos nicht
löschen dürfen formal müssen sie das
nichtbeachten aber wenn man anstand
hätte und sich dem deutschen recht
beugen würde würde man die videos wieder
online stellen sowie youtube kennen
machen sie es aber nicht einsatz noch
dazu wir hatten vor kurzem eine
einstweilige verfügung des
oberlandesgerichts dresden erwirkt da
das drei wochen gedauert bis das video
wieder online war und sie haben ja auch
darüber berichtet dass hat dann ein
ordnungsgeld von 100.000 euro gesetzt
und das wird hoffentlich wirkung zeigen
sie sprechen es gerade andreas
steinhöfel die wirkung jetzt aber noch
die frage auf das urteil von gestern
bezogen wir erleben dass immer wieder
sie uns auch angesprochen dass dinge
gelöscht werden für wie groß halten sie
denn die signalwirkung des urteils von
gestern
was ganz ganz wichtig ist es nicht nur
dass wir immer und immer wieder
prozessuale erfolge gegen die sozialen
plattformen haben wir eine erfolgsquote
von 90 95 prozent also wir gewinnen fast
alles es sei denn wir gehen risiken ein
weil man neuland betritt aber was
natürlich auch ganz wichtig ist dass die
medien darüber berichten und wenn man
solche fälle hat wo prominente
schauspieler dabei sind fällt das
natürlich leichter bild hat jetzt
diverse male berichtet diese sache ist
auch überall aufgenommen worden
süddeutsche faz zeitspiegel und so
weiter und das ist ganz wichtig um den
menschen zu zeigen was da geschieht bei
jeder raus vielleicht auch politischen
druck sich entwickeln zu lassen und das
bewusstsein zu schärfen man kann mit
aussicht auf erfolg dagegen vorgehen man
muss sich das nicht bieten lassen und
das dümmliche gerede sorry um so
genannten hausrecht nachdem die sozialen
plattformen machen können was sie wollen
ist eben das was sie eben sagte unfug
das dürfen sie nicht die grundrechte
spielen ganz massiv mit in das rein weil
es eben monopolisten sind darauf wollte
ich gerade meine frage auch abzählen wie
bewerten sie das dass konzerne
letztendlich darüber entscheiden dann
was gesagt werden davon was nicht
und man kann sich vor gericht dagegen
wehren aber in wesentlichen teil dazu
beigetragen
hat ja die große koalition heiko maas
angela merkel die die treibenden kräfte
hinter dem unmöglich benannten netzwerk
durch setzungen gesetzt waren wenn sie
als bild zeitung nur mal unterstellt
oder eine andere zeitung eine ganz
schwere
persönlichkeitsrechtsverletzung begehen
würden und würden eine einstweilige
verfügung vom gericht und dagegen
verstoßen ist das schlimmste was
passieren kann das ist im gesetz
vorgesehen an ordnungsgeld von 250.000
euro in diesem netz ag steht drin dass
selbst die leitenden mitarbeiter
der social media konzerne also nicht nur
das unternehmen dass wir geld hat
sondern auch die persönlich
verantwortlichen bis zu 50 millionen
euro auf die uhr kriegen können das ist
das 200 fache dessen was einem großen
medienkonzern brot wenn er eine
einstweilige verfügung verletzt ergebnis
ist doch dass die leute sagen im zweifel
lösche ich das lieber bevor ich mich
hier persönlich mit meinem hab und gut
ein gefährliches terrain gebe und das
führt zum sogenannten overclocking es
wird viel mehr gelöscht alsmann löschen
dürfte nicht umsonst die vielen prozesse
die wir führen und das mit erfolg aber
der gesetzgeber es mitverantwortlich
herzlichen dank an den anwalt joachim
steinhöfel der in diesem fall alles auf
den tisch ein erfolg den rechtlichen
erfolg juristischen erfolg gegen youtube
gefeiert hat und er ja weiter kämpfen
wird für offene diskussionen der gerne
provoziert und der es uns manchmal auch
ja relativ leicht macht eine tolle eine
leidenschaftliche diskussion zu führen
und das wollen wir hier bei bild eben
auch in unseren sendungen immer weiter
tun
[Musik]